yeah i think so i think it definitely
felt like uh the old days of just the
seahawks and 49ers are going back and
forth
um you know it's 2019 version you know
and a lot of great players on that field
tonight um you know and uh i know a lot
of people probably had to stay up and
watch it but it was uh it was worth
watching
russell wilson the guy who
led the seahawks to one most unlikely i
couldn't even see him that camouflaged
jacket where was he
that is unreal
but let me tell you if you're gonna if
you're gonna do the veterans day tribute
right you can throw on the nfl issue
salute to service gear or you can go get
yourself a camouflage and i think that
looks like it's velour or velvet i like
that i could not pull that off i am
willing to say i could not pull that off
you could not pull that off no russell
wilson can pull that off you're right
and i forgot about the veterans day
connection it's early in the morning but
that's exactly why he wore it and that
is it's kind of a good under the well
it's not so under the radar tribute
there but it's uh it's something it's an
unbelievable jacket all right let's go
after yeah
well first of all let me say hello to
everyone out there it's pft live nbc
sports radio nbcsn we have to say
greetings as usual to our friends in the
uk and in ireland and they're making all
sorts of suggestions about the next time
we make a bet you know when you try to
get me to wear kirk cousins jersey again
right there are ideas as to the or else
for you one of our friends in the uk
suggested that you should have to wear a
jim harbaugh jersey that will never
happen on any occasion
i have standards i will never wear his
jersey for any bet so we can find
something else but it won't be jim i can
tell you that
bears or cults i'll let you decide which
one all right let's get to it though
last night it was a great great game a
memorable game chris you nailed it top
of the hour game of the year really find
a better game this year find a more
impactful game you got an 8-0 team
against a 7-2 team and they traded
punches this was
rocky ii right i mean knockout punch
after knockout punch back and forth over
and over again until we finally got to
the end and the swings were incredible
it all came down to overtime and it
looked like the seahawks were going to
win with a touchdown on the opening
drive of overtime just like they did a
week earlier against the buccaneers then
the incredible interception by dre
greenlaw how many balls did we see
seahawks defenders not catch right green
law made that catch look easy and then i
thought he was gonna chris did you think
he was gonna run in for a touchdown i
thought it was over right there i did i
thought it was deep trouble the way he
took off and then i went oh i hope
russell wilson gets up in a hurry to
make the make it over there then i saw
him get blocked and he made a little cut
back and i went oh gosh he's going to go
to the house but uh they did rally to
tackle but
like mike you're the apollo i mean you
know apollo creed rocky 2 all of that
that's really where i want to start the
conversation to me that was the number
one thing that jumps out to me about the
game the physicality i think it was the
mo one of the most physical football
games i have watched in a while i mean
they were out there hitting each other
on both sides of the ball
and the 49ers this year have out hit
everybody they've played on their
schedule steelers gave him a little run
for the money but they still even out
hit them and that's saying something
because the steelers usually out hit
everybody too but the seahawks came in
and said hey wait we're we're used to
being the bullies in the nfc west like
we're ready to hit too and they let it
be known and
the master of f the play-up was hitting
people everywhere and here he goes with
the picking up the fumble jaedevian
clowney i was just glad to see everybody
got to watch him on a big stage and how
dominant he can be because he's been
doing this for about the last three or
four years
yeah but last night it seemed like he
found a higher level his best game by
far with the seahawks he was dominant he
was destructive he was disruptive and
chris look and you're right there are so
many different ways we can take this
let's go ahead and crap on jimmy g for a
minute here we had said all year at some
point he's going to have to step up and
play and he made some plays against the
cardinals when the running game wasn't
as as easily there as it had been and he
had to make some throws and and and
deliver the victory that thursday night
a week and a half ago but last night it
was all on him and it was a different
offense without george kittle it was a
different offense once emanuel sanders
exited and jimmy garoppolo could not
carry it well yes he had his moments and
like you said i mean i don't know what
do you think there was like
realistically maybe three or four
dropped interceptions in the game
basically by the seahawks i mean there
was two on the very last drive of the
game to kick the game tying field goal
to send it into overtime um now the
other interception we just showed there
that went through you know bourne's
hands that wasn't his fault uh he also
let's not forget this it's 21 to 18 and
they're down there again uh in the area
at that point trying to to tie the game
and they have bourne drops a third down
pass that's gonna give them first and
goal at the four or five but if you're
watching on tv this first out route to
bourne yeah that wasn't jimmy dre's
fault yes he's not a superstar he's
still working his way through
he i you know what do i want to say here
i'm not concerned about him but i'm
still not sold that he can carry the
team in these type of moments i guess is
what i'm trying to say but but here's
and here's the thing and we know
football teams do this every year they
evaluate every position they they take
the name off the back of the jersey and
they make that that tough decision if
need be that it's time to consider an
upgrade and you know as the 49ers were
winning game after game after game after
game the notion that jimmy garoppolo is
in a make or break up or out year fell
by the wayside because they're winning
nobody cares right right but
if he becomes the weak link offensively
if he becomes the weak link
among all of the players who are on the
field offensively and defensively and
you have a contract where the way you've
structured it you can take until april 1
to make a decision at a minimum kyle
shanahan and john lynch are going to
look around and see what their options
are how can you not if you think that if
you could upgrade the quarterback
position you go from being a team that
gets knocked out in the divisional round
or the nfc championship because this
same kind of thing plays out where the
quarterback can't step up and deliver in
a big spot sure and you consider what
you can do for 2020 well sure yes i i i
mean if we continue to see these type of
moments that that time will come uh i
think though still as far as last
night's like concerned i don't think i'm
going to like panic yet now you know you
said it jimmy garoppolo it wasn't great
uh was he the weak link on the field i'm
not gonna say that i'm gonna say joe
staley at left tackle was the weak link
on the field last night more than
anything i mean that was an issue and
then hey we do have to mention no george
kittle noah manuel sanders those are
those are big injuries for that football
team george kittle is by far their best
offensive weapon not having him out
there was huge
it takes away a huge aspect of their
football i mean of their football game
planning all the things they do off of
their run game and then feature kittle
and play action passes and boots and
other little creative ways so i'm not
hitting the panic button yet there were
still some good things that jimmy
garoppolo did i i'm not going gonna go
there yet but it is still a little bit
in the let's continue to evaluate this
guy uh and see where it goes from here
and if we see three four more games like
this and they come up on you know the
the short end of them then you're right
come you know march they're going to
have some conversations but i don't
think we're there yet to hit the panic
button
i'd love to know what marquise goodwin
did to upset kyle shanahan i mean he was
in a healthy scratch for a couple of
weeks once emanuel sanders arrived he
dressed last night he had three targets
no catches he's just become the
forgotten man in that offense and they
must believe that that they just can't
count on him when when uh they need him
and you know the running game they
couldn't count on it last night either
they threw the ball 46 times ran it 27
times and once they fell behind 21 to 10
and it looked like the seahawks were
going to pull away
you know it i can understand why you're
leaning on the pass but when you get the
lightning strike eight point play from
that goofy exchange where russell
wilson's being sacked the ball pops into
the hands of jermaine and fetty he
decides he's gonna be jerome bettis
instead and then the ball gets punched
out deforest buckner scores it's 21-18 i
felt like at that point you could try to
get back to running the football and try
to re-establish there but they still
leaned on the passing game more than
they should have yeah well i agreed i
mean it's as much as we've seen them
lean on the passing game all year but
the big thing is and you know i thought
the guys on the telecast booger
mcfarland did a good job at least of
saying hey the seahawks are they're
crowding the line of scrimmage they're
calling the 49ers bluff basically saying
we dare you to throw it
we're going to dare you to and
because of that i think kyle shanahan
saw some of those looks and he said man
it's going to be tough sledding run of
the ball tonight and he decided to go
another direction but again even with
that game plan it accentuates even more
that there's no emanuel sanders and
george kittle and back to your marquis
goodwin thing i think the marquis
goodwin issue more than anything is he's
kind of a one-trick pony he's just a
really a deep shot let's run him on a
post route let's run him on a go route
and these other receivers he has right
now are kind of more versatile and able
to do different things for their offense
so he can mix and match and you can't
really get a telltale sign on oh this
guy does this and then that guy does
that you know with debo samuel bourne
emmanuel sanders they can all do
everything so you don't know where
they're going to attack you uh but
regardless i mean i just i can't get
over the game and the defensive players
in this game holy cow it's one beast
after another it's the oregon tree
trunks in the middle bosa d ford clowney
jaron reed i mean holy cow was it
unbelievable some of the hitting we had
it all last night fumbles great plays
annoying refs it was it encompassed it
all in the nfl
and there was a great sense of timing by
the san francisco defense they would
step up and make a big play on russell
wilson and just just engulf him in
bodies on a third down yeah right and
there weren't a ton of sacks
but they would happen at a time when the
49ers needed them and a credit to that
offensive line and the way they designed
the play keep russell wilson from
spinning and and sprinting out of the
pocket like he always does that's what
mike zimmer does when he faces russell
wilson but also the pressure up the
middle to close the deal once you
prevent him from doing the trademark
spin and escape then you bring somebody
up the middle and he can't do anything
yeah now look he he still played well
uh the the seahawks did enough it wasn't
spectacular they got 89 rushing yards
out of chris carson they had a a good
not great performance from dk metcalf
the rookie receiver jacob hollister
stepping up with eight catches for 62
yards and two big catches for josh
gordon in big spots third down throws to
josh gordon not not not the kind of
thing that's going to excite fantasy
owners but the kind of thing is going to
excite seahawks fans if he becomes the
guy you can count on on third down
that's right you have an element that
you were missing with the retirement of
doug baldwin yeah the the he is he's
he's a go-to guy in those big situations
and you know what we saw brady go to him
a lot over the last two years in those
type of situations you know he's he
scares you you know dbs are always going
to be on their heels a little bit
because they'll go oh he might run by me
or he might catch a back shoulder and
then he runs a slant route or something
in breaking and he's very warm and cozy
for a quarterback because he's a giant
human being he's one of the biggest
receivers you'll ever see on the planet
and so when he runs a slant or a post
route you just feel like wow his big
body his long arms his radius it's going
to be hard for a defender to break that
ball up if i just throw a semi-accurate
football and that's where he came in
clutch for them last night in the fourth
quarter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports